my guest tonight is a comedian who is of
course a cast member on Saturday Night
Live and also starred in 30 rock now you
can see him in the last oh gee on TBS I
am thrilled Tracy Morgan okay I don't
know what you're talking about
listen we got we got to start first of
all what that is your own fish tank
behind you yeah that is is this right
the fourth largest private fish tank in
the world this is not a fish tank does
this look like a fish a fish is a fish
bowl that's something you'd buy a Coney
Island this is an aquarium okay I'm
sorry you have your own private aquarium
those you can't keep ahead you have
sharks in there that's a shark not some
big boys in there okay I hope you don't
lose an arm
why would you suddenly talk like a
pirate if you lost your arm Tracy you're
in quarantine how are you passing the
time I'll owe you amusing yourself get
my wife pregnant two babies you have Q
on the way do one away every week it's
okay so it's not twins you're saying
okay okay so you
used to see Georgia coronavirus baby
okay that's something they can know
their whole life middle-aged men is
still bolded
yeah that's good to know god you're not
born it we quarantine well how long
crazy how long have you been in
quarantine how long you been in
quarantine for 20 minutes I got a cousin
around you don't have a car he's a pimp
so he would advance for he you got my
money my Sheila fair with 10 kids and
she can't afford though man
so she using one hot Browns with some
rubber bands she said in the 66 WD
family my family shake cuz she got the
big jobs
she got titties so she's got a 66 double
D bra 1 cup 1 cup covered Tracy are you
are you prepared for this virus do you
have everything you need let's say
government chief government and
everything if the kid is what my
grandmother told me to put it
get some cocoa butter lotion get some
peroxide cuz peroxide cure anything
oh wait a minute what is it cocoa butter
lotion do what do you think I gotta cut
my grandmother put some cocoa butter on
it so you think cocoa butter is gonna be
the cure for coronavirus it is cocoa
butter
okay okay okay Tracy there's a lot of
misinformation out there
and I worry you're telling people to
stock up on government cheese and that
cocoa butter will cure the corona virus
let me tell you you had the five
percenters right yeah Papa Sydney did
one guy that changed his name to
asymptomatic what he changed mad at God
a lot but he has a pre-existing medical
condition no no it was what was it he's
a stupid book you know what you're
sharks have to listen to this
all day long first of all okay you
mentioned toilet paper do you have
enough toilet paper Tracy take one per
day just don't conserve so only people
can always burn most son got a stomach
that look like The Little Rascals cake
number five at the gate is their stomach
so wait a minute so people can urinate
but they can't the other one they can't
do you got a right your booty though
I like delivery one I like how everyone
else is talking to doctor foul Qi and
I'm talking to you don't you're killing
me I'm gonna fall I'm not corrode and
doing this to me oh yeah all this
craziness all right